[Música]
i
desde que era chiquitito me gustaba
mirar al cielo estrellado por la noche y
pensar si habría otros mundos desde
afuera y si podría haber algo viendo en
ellos es probablemente una de las
preguntas más importantes que se haya
hecho la humanidad prácticamente casi
todos los días se descubre un nuevo
sistema planetario que se ve similar al
de la tierra con esto me refiero a
planetas que cuentan con características
similares a las de la tierra
probablemente un planeta rocoso donde
las temperaturas estén dentro del marco
en que la vida pueda ser viable también
una atmósfera que cuente con elementos
básicos como el nitrógeno o el oxígeno
pero más importante aún es la capacidad
de un planeta por almacenar a chorro en
estado líquido a chorro o agua como lo
quieran llamar que es la base de la vida
que conocemos
aunque no lo crean las pistas sobre la
vida extraterrestre están oculta de
nuestro planeta y el primer paso para
entender qué tan probable es que haya
vida en otros planetas es entender que
hizo que la vida sea posible en nuestro
planeta hace unos cuatro mil millones de
años fue el momento en que la vida
surgió uno podría pensar que una vez que
la vida comienza su recorrido el camino
las criaturas complejas como los
animales o las plantas fue bastante
sencillo pero no es como parece la vida
podría haber permanecido sencilla y
pequeña pero no fue así
evolucionó derivando en las ocho
millones de especies que conocemos
actualmente y esto hablando solamente de
los grupos bien conocidos como mamíferos
y plantas donde los organismos son
visibles distinguibles y de interés
taxonómica
es una ley de la naturaleza que la vida
evoluciona para adaptarse
así que si encontramos vida en otros
planetas lo más probable es que esa vida
sea la más adecuada para prosperar en
esas condiciones sólo imagínense cuán
peculiar podría parecerles unos
hormigueros si nunca hubieran visto uno
podrían pensar que es una criatura de
otro planeta pero en realidad no su
diseño extraño tiene perfecto sentido
para la forma en que se relaciona con su
entorno y la forma en que obtiene su
alimento como sus patas que están
provistas unas poderosas garras capaces
de destrozar los primeros para después
con la con su alargada lengua obtener el
alimento el alimento que posteriormente
le brindará la energía para sobrevivir
ustedes podrían pensar que para sostener
a una criatura compleja como los
hormigueros se requieren grandes
cantidades de energía pero incluso un
microbio pequeño también tiene demandas
energéticas es por eso que cuando
pensamos en la vida lo primero que se
nos viene a la mente son los organismos
visibles los animales las plantas pero
en realidad la mayoría de los organismos
vivientes
organismos unicelulares virus y
bacterias que se han adaptado para vivir
en casi cualquier entorno hoy en día los
científicos tienen registro de bacterias
viendo en las cimas de las montañas en
los desiertos en el fondo y en el fondo
del mar e incluso a miles de metros de
la atmósfera terrestre es muy probable
que más allá de nuestro sistema solar
existan este tipo de microbios yendo en
entornos que probablemente tal y tal la
vida tal y como la conocemos aquí en la
tierra no podría tolerar
hasta cierto tiempo en la historia de la
tierra la energía provenía de los
respiradores volcánicos una vez que la
tierra comenzó a enfriarse y comenzó a
cambiar se necesitaba una nueva fuente
de energía
esta fuente de energía surgió por la
energía que venía de la luz solar las
bacterias que vivían en ese momento
tuvieron que adaptarse y usar el nuevo
mecanismo usar la energía proveniente de
la luz solar para potenciar su
crecimiento estos organismos
posteriormente evolucionaron y derivaron
en creaturas más complejas como las
plantas que las tenemos hoy en día lo
que las plantas hacen es utilizar la
energía proveniente la luz solar y la
usan para convertir el dióxido de
carbono en almidón gránulos de energía
almacenada que las plantas usan vargas
para potenciar su crecimiento pero si
las plantas almacenan energía no debió
haber pasado mucho tiempo para que
alguien evolucione y le sacará provecho
a esto es por eso que cuando un animal
se como una planta el animal está
ingiriendo toda la energía
la planta capturo de la luz solar todo
esto que les estoy contando significa
que el sol cumple un rol fundamental en
el ciclo de la vida lo que nos lleva a
la siguiente pregunta podrían otras
estrellas alimentar bien en otros
planetas para entender cuán probable es
esto primero tenemos que entender el
número de estrellas en la vía láctea
los científicos actualmente calculan el
número de estrellas con una compleja
ecuación
la respuesta es de alrededor de unas
300.000 millones y si escalamos eso a
granos de arena necesitaríamos una pila
de 416 toneladas de arena para igualar
el número de granos de arena con
estrellas en la vía láctea igualmente me
resulta un poco abstracto hablarles
solamente de
de números por eso es que acá les traza
una imagen y esta es la vía láctea
obviamente no es la vía láctea pero es
una pila de 416 toneladas unos 300.000
millones grano arenas individuales y
agarramos 1
como este obviamente no lo pueden ver
pero éste representaría nuestro sol esta
analogía me parecía perfecta para
demostrarles lo que es la diversidad de
nuestro universo si nuestro sol
realmente fuera un grano de arena la
tierra sería el tamaño glóbulo rojo y la
estrella más cercana al sistema solar
proxima centauri estaría ubicada a 14,2
kilómetros de distancia ahora por un
lado tomando conciencia de todos los
requisitos que debe tener un planeta
además de todos los procesos por lo que
tuvo que pasar la tierra para que hoy en
día podemos decir somos una especie de
civilizada una especie volución nada y
por el otro tomando dimensión de lo que
realmente es nuestro universo podemos
volver a la pregunta inicial habrá vida
allá afuera en una parte
personalmente creo que sí perdón
personalmente creo que si hay vida
a ver muchas también pero no hay una
buena probabilidad de que mientras
miramos esas estrellas no hace nada ni
remotamente parecido a lo que pensamos
mirándonos consideren esto a gran escala
el universo es como un torbellino de
galaxias
se calcula que hay unos 200.000 millones
esto es prácticamente una galaxia en el
universo por cada estrella la vía láctea
si imaginamos que la cada galaxia
albergar a tan solo una sola
la civilización tecnológicamente
avanzada entonces había miles de
millones de posibilidades de vida
extraterrestre en el universo abundaría
la vida inteligente de ahora en adelante
espero que la próxima vez queda en el
cielo misionero no lo vean de la misma
manera en que lo veían antes gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]